the Fiji Islands where jet setters like
to take their vacations at luxury hotels
we take a look behind the scenes at how
local island inhabitants spend their
days not far from the airport on the
main island there's a small River
flowing south and right next to it a
poverty-stricken settlement most
ground-floor housing has been abandoned
Dinesh whose parents came here from
India owns an upholstery store which he
runs from the upper level of the
building a lot of things from down
everything was the way so it's better
for me now rainy weather like that I
walk from this series of disasters began
in 2012 when category 4 cyclone Evan hit
Fiji had never experienced this much
rain the areas surrounding Corriveau
tube became a lake district there was
just too much rain for the local stream
Dinesh takes us there he shows us the
shore which is much higher than usual
increasing the damage this is where
things went wild with flash flooding
the last two years back was a very bad
one it was the worst one we saw these
are very bad one yeah it happened in so
fast that we even couldn't move our
things we were trapped inside the house
now what I just does the banging just
came in Shh in 2016 there was a category
5 cyclone named Winston this was the
worst storm ever to hit Fiji here
cyclones are out of the ordinary the
Pacific Ocean seemed to be going out of
control the locals on Fiji are now
concerned about the extreme heat of the
summers during cyclone Winston the
temperature on the water's surface
reached up to 30 degrees Celsius during
the storms the rivers rose and spread
steadily across the island that's
wreaking even more havoc after the storm
provisional bridges were built in Kirov
Udo but because of climate change no one
knows if the floods will return and
possibly be even worse the residents
here may be forced to move elsewhere but
they can't afford to do so we went there
and after that it was a big big flood
and nothing inside the house again no
I'm not seeing no more clothes
everything nothing left that's a big
flood our bed to freeze everything lost
climate change is making life here
dangerous and not only along the coast
Dinesh has experienced this firsthand
the violent storms and heavy rainfall
transformed their stream into a raging
river that destroyed the neighborhood